[Music]
looks normal to me when did this start
happen since Helen got the job I assume
she knows are you kidding I can't tell
her about this not while she's doing
hero work I've got to succeed so she can
succeed so we can't succeed it Bob
I get it when was the last time you
slept who keeps track of that besides
he's a baby I can handle it I got this
handle so you're good then you got
everything under control
right he can still hear you on the other
dimension yeah that is freaky I can't
steer enough stop it and the under
miners escape
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no alas disciple you asked to cycle I
didn't know you had a I had a mohawk
there's a lot about me you don't know
yeah
Mohawk you didn't miss anything yeah
this one's electric what something means
it's
you will be great I will be great and
you will do we will both be great
[Music]
[Music]
what exactly is mom's new job she's an
advocate for superheroes but I thought
superheroes were still illegal so things
haven't spiraled out of control the
moment I left looks normal to me I'll be
there
it's up to us
hey little baby those two tickets down
repeat gee honey she's an artist she is
the history of fashion like no other
designer she's a legend modern graphic
she's explosive yes I'm sure your
gratitude is quite inexpressible I first
encounter Edna's work I remember sitting
in Paris along darling Lila hmm she's
very intimidating outrageous you love
can't leave I've admitted to face a
figure that cycle in siog Louis Vuitton
Edna she's a visionary a giant I mean
well not literally she comes up to my
knees my favorite I had new pieces the
nuclear ones the rocket stilettos
everyone has said apiece don't ask me to
do it again darling my rates are far too
have you ever heard anything so
different and they can't all pull it off
I'm not all dark and angsty Elastigirl
Edna designed this no some guy named
Alexander gehlbach I would say Edna mode
is like the modern-day Andy Warhol but I
think Andy Warhol looked up to her bravo
Bravo darling no bill will be covered by
my feet for being mr. incredible
Elastigirl and frozen's exclusive
designer throughout the known universe
and until the end of time
[Music]
a might get weird
heavy weight problems need heavyweight
solutions miss.jeong panels knives here
oh no you can team up with mr.
incredible leave the shaking the world
to the men
[Music]
watch out bad guys no you can team up
with Elastigirl
I love my elastic girl together you can
stop any villain your elastic her over
ever toys are sold as always
I'll be the patient
no you can team up with frozen frozen
wherever toys are sold the Incredibles
back hang out with them again everybody
fell in love we tee I'll watch the kids
no problem it's exciting to see these
amazing actors back hello Wow
come on get yourself together Carrie so
yeah I'm trying to play it cool honey
great he's in excellent health I think
what separates the Incredibles from
other superhero stories this is
fundamentally a story about a family
[Music]
know that way and their normal seasons
so fun juxtaposed with this unbelievable
heroic action that they are taking the
push for superhero legalization is
becoming a worldwide movement he loves
superheroes and he wants to have them
come out from hiding remember that these
are people who fight the good fight so
this theme that you should be allowed to
be who you are I think it's such a
universal story that anybody can
understand help my family I gotta leave
it to fix the law I gotta break it you
got to the toy kids can have that choice
the strength that they call from is the
connection between them which is the
most important part we've got this
I'm just so excited for audiences to see
it and continue the legacy of who his
family is
combustion imminent what does that mean
it means fire rapid they're called many
super incredible the strongest did you
wash your hands with soap did you dry
them I did so are we going to talk about
it what the elephant in the room what
elephant
mom's new job
it's time to make some wrong things
right hell they bring supers back into
the sunlight we need to change people's
perceptions about superheroes and
Elastigirl is our best play better than
me I watch the kids no problem do it dad
they want us to do it I don't know that
way why would they change math math is
Batman hello hey honey
kit everything's great
[Music]
he's in excellent health is freaky you
know it's crazy right to help my family
I gotta leave it to fix the law I gotta
break it you've got to destroy kids can
have that choice thank you young man
combustion imminent what does that mean
it means fire Robert
[Music]
the screen sledder interrupts this
program for an important announcement
weird I'll be there powers
mythic struggle superheroes
suit up it might get weird I'll be there
[Music]
hey little baby where are your parents
ours
Incredibles - rated PG tickets available
now
I thought we were gonna get heard your
mother trampolining
superheroes are illegal you want to
fight bad guys defines Who I am
we're not saying you have watch someone
on TV sitting I was approached by this
tycoon must talk about hero stuff help
me bring supers back into the sunlight
we need Elastigirl
[Music]
there's no problem not the way you're
supposed to do it dad they want us to do
it I don't know that way why would they
change math over Dusseldorf do those are
dogging Kyle is so heavy to pee
[Music]
closer
I couldn't have done this if you hadn't
taken over so well I've got to succeed
so she can succeed
you can sit Bob is freaky but I can't
keep done properly parenting is a heroic
action done properly
hello honey things haven't spiraled up
control the moment I left Oh
everything's great mom is doing your
work done properly parenting is their
heroic looks normal to me is freaky
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you have
[Music]
[Music]